a perilous path to poland
is only the beginning
refugees from the war in ukraine keep
going
exhausted
they begin another difficult journey
many board trains leaving eastern poland
not knowing where their last stop will
be
one woman overwhelmed tired barely able
to speak
said she left her whole family back in
ukraine
her husband is fighting in the war
children are caring for her elderly
mother who's too old to leave
carrying what little she can she's
heading west hoping to find work
perhaps a new home for her family
when we met her on the train
she said she had not slept in four days
is going back to her job in warsaw after
volunteering at the border she was
mostly greeting refugees for example
yesterday i saw a woman with her
grandson and she was
crying so i said
upon to her and we were talking a little
bit i don't know ukrainian language but
it's similar to polish language so she
was talking about her family
her husband her home that she
has left now
so the support emotional support is
something that i think they need the
most
if the war continues she says more
volunteers will need to go to the border
something as simple as a warm welcome at
poland's door
can make those forced out of their
country
feel more at home
[Applause]
two years old tamur is too young to
understand that he's been uprooted by
war
[Music]
his father is fighting russian forces in
donbass
fleeing the violence his mother says was
their only choice
what can people do now they can only run
with their children we were hesitating
for a long time about what we should do
but i think it was the right decision
every train going west is filled
with stories of lives torn apart by war
millions of vulnerable civilians forced
to find a fresh start
once the train pulls into krakow station
people step off the platform into a kind
of controlled chaos now it is hectic
here but there is help to be had there's
volunteers handing out food
available to answer any questions people
might have and helping people register
to find a place to live
on the train some do find their way
overhearing her story agnieszka far from
the border but still helping
offers a ride and a place to stay to a
new friend
safe passage and safe haven
new beginnings in krakow
a city that has known war
now a place of refuge
and resistance
not the closest kind zayn bastravi
al-jazeera krakow